انطلقت في مدينه جنيفر السويسريه اجتماعات
مجلس حقوق الانسان بمشاركه وزير الخارجي
الايراني اكبر حسين الذي سيلقي كلمه شخصيا
امام مجلس ياتي ذلك وسط دعوات من ناشطين
ايرانيين ومنظمات حقوقيه بمقاطعه كلمته
بسبب قمع النظام الاحتجاجات وفي هذا
السياق تشارك روسيا التي انسحبت من المجلس
العام الماضي بناء بوزير خارجيتها الذي
ينضم للاجتماعات لاحقا خلال هذا الاسبوع
انعقاد هذا الاجتماع وما هي ابرز الملفات
التي ستناقش ستناقش
يعني هو ابي الاجتماعات دوريه لمجلس حقوق
الانسان يعني بدا هذه
الدوره اليوم قبل قليل بطبيعه الحال يعني
هناك اهتمام كبير من المجتمع الدولي
بقضايا الانسان او بحقوق الانسان في ايران
كان هناك جنس خاصه لهذا المجلس في نوفمبر
الماضي خصفت بالمناقشه وضع حقوق الانسان
في ايران بسبب قمع النظام الاحتجاجات
والان يعني اختار دقيقه ومديره خارجيه ان
ياتي الى هنا شخصيا ويتحدث الى المجلس كما
ذكرت هناك يعني دعوات منشطين ومنظمات
حقوقيه تطالب بان يكون هناك مقاطعه لكلمه
وزير خارجيه الايراني ولكن هو على ما يبدو
يعني يستغل هذه الخنقه
ايران مستعده الان للعوده هو كان هناك
كلام فيه الوسائل الاعلام الايرانيه سنفعل
اللقاء بعدد من المسؤولين الغربيين وهو
بالفعل التقى بصباحا
يعني وزير خارجيه الموجود هنا
غير واضح ما اذا كان سيلتقي بالوزراء
خارجيه اخرون لانه وزيره خارجيه فرنسا
وزيره خارجيه المانيا
مستبعد جدا ان يكون هناك لقاء بينهما ولكن
يعني من دون شاب مساله حقوق الانسان في
ايران تكون يعني حاضره في كلمات المتحدثين
ايضا الوضع في روسيا لانه يعني رغم انه
روسيا قالت لانها ستعلق الانسان العام
الماضي ولكن هناك مسؤوليتي نائب وزير
خارجيه موجود هنا سيحصل الى هنا يوم
الخميس هذا الاجتماعات تستمر خمسه اسابيع
لذلك هو ايضا يعني سنتحدث او سيلتقي
بمجموعه هنا من الاشخاص ويعطي يعني موقف
روسيا من الالتهابات المواجهه اليها حول
حقوق الانسان
وحول في اوكرانيا